welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series i am your host greg
knuckles i'm joined today by special
temporary guest co-host eric trexler
eric how are you doing i'm doing very
well thank you for having me
yeah thanks for coming on uh it's been a
while since we've done a fireside chat
so just to remind
everyone how things go around here uh
this is not a fitness and or
science focused episode this is just a
chat between
friends we're keeping it light we're
keeping it good vibes only
uh and yeah this is going to be kind of
our
2020 year in review fireside chat
episode
and looking ahead to 2021
we're recording this on january 5th so
let me start by saying happy new year to
everyone
uh since we're recording this on january
5th
that means the holiday season is finally
over uh
what officially marks the end of the
holiday season is the end of
toyotathon as we all know that ended on
january 4th so we are
officially out of the holidays and into
the new year proper
so uh yeah let's uh let's look back and
look ahead
yeah quick question when do the happy
honda days
end i believe happy honda days does end
at some point in december okay cool then
yeah we should be
we should be in the clear and ready to
begin a new year yeah
and of course the lexus december to
remember sales event that is
fully self-contained within december
yeah as we all know
um so yeah uh before we get started
actually i do need to address
the elephant in the room uh being the
elephant
in the last episode of the podcast uh
i forget the context for this but we got
very off topic and i mentioned
that uh ancient folks probably
came up with the idea of cyclopses
because they came across the skull of an
elephant which has
just one big hole in the middle of the
head uh i
incorrectly said that that is where both
the like eye stuff and also nasal stuff
was
that is in fact just the nasal stuff uh
the eye
the eye holes for elephants are on the
sides of the head
uh i need to correct myself there
in my defense i was mainly making a
point about cyclopses there
there is a finite amount of time to do
pre-episode research
and most of the research heading into
that episode
i was focusing on the anatomy of
cryptids
instead of the anatomy of pachyderms um
so yeah that's a hundred percent on me
uh we were thinking about
making this a pachyderm podcast moving
it
into 2021 i fear that
i have unfortunately already shot all of
our pachyderm credibility in the foot
so we might be forced to stick with
fitness stuff
um so that's unfortunate but it's fine
and the thing to me that's really
disappointing is
um i've actually been withholding a lot
of human good news
but i've been purposely trying to focus
on animal good news to give us a little
bit of a runway kind of a pathway toward
a more animal focused show in general as
a spin-off and i feel like a lot of that
was just wasted effort at this point but
we'll continue doing human and fitness
stuff for the time being
all right uh so yeah let's uh let's kick
this episode off by talking about
lessons we learned in 2020 do you wanna
do you wanna start us off tracks
i absolutely do so yeah we're gonna talk
a little bit about lessons learned and
then kind of what we're focusing on some
of our goals for 2021.
i do want to put a caveat at the
beginning of the episode
so the fireside chats we do not do
thorough research for and apparently
even for our normal episodes we don't
because we're just
botching elephant facts left and right
but like i'm going to be talking about
some things when it comes to goal
setting that like
research exists and i have not read it
[Laughter]
so so just to frame this for the reader
because one of the things that does get
under my skin
is if you do evidence-based stuff
and like you say four things that are
evidence-based
and three that just kind of feel good
and you don't tell people which are
which
and so like someone listening can't tell
which of those is just your hot take and
what is actually evidence based
so like if you're listening along
imagine you're around the dinner table
with greg and i and we're just spouting
off about what we want to do next year
and just kind of say this seems like a
good goal to me
we haven't thoroughly reviewed the goal
setting literature so
take it with a grain of salt anyway
we're talking first about lessons
learned so
you know i i thought that 2020 just kind
of looking back at things i noticed
along with things i learned in 2020 it
was a really solid year
for research in my opinion and i
mostly follow the sports nutrition
literature so literature about getting
leaner stronger more muscular performing
better etc
so i thought there was a lot of cool
stuff this year about nitric oxide
boosters which have a special place in
my heart because that was what my
dissertation research was about
really cool stuff about glycogen and
carb availability
um you know every month we do an
internal peer review of our mass
articles
and helms and i spent far too much time
this year getting really into the
nuanced interpretation of glycogen and
carbohydrate research
and it just gets more interesting the
deeper you go there's some
cool stuff about insulin sensitivity and
hypertrophy and we're still kind of
pouring through some of that research as
we speak
and and i think we're going to have more
content coming out about that eventually
and also caffeine and genetics you know
caffeine and genetics was one of those
things i wrote a book chapter
co-authored a book chapter about
caffeine
only a few years ago and they were like
eric you cover the genetics part
and at that point there was like a
couple studies
about these different genotypes that
seemed influential but
you know we'll have to wait and see and
then a couple studies came out that
really reinforced oh this is really
important and i was like damn i wish
those were around when i wrote that
chapter because i left it very
uh ambiguous kind of equivocal and now
now things are starting to turn the
other way and now i'm like thank god
that stuff wasn't available when i wrote
that book chapter because i would just
be wrong as hell
um but yeah a lot of really interesting
stuff going on um
now in general so i i didn't have a
portion in my outline talking about
research stuff so i'm just gonna slot in
here real quick sure
do it uh on your show that is true yeah
uh so on the training side of things a
few
areas where also the the research did
kind of blow up this year
there was a ton of stuff on
velocity-based training that uh
that area of of the literature really
really
matured this year i would say uh and
one of the other areas where i was kind
of surprised
by both how many research results there
were
and how positive they tended to be um
was on what i guess i would call like
technological aids for training so we
we talked about um photo therapy
low-level laser therapy on a on a
previous episode of the podcast
uh there's more stuff that's come out
about that it still does
seem to be quite positive which still
does kind of surprise me but you know it
is what it is
uh there have recently been i'd say in
the last six months or so there have
been
four or five pretty decent studies on um
hypoxic preconditioning so basically
uh before training you
basically like cut off blood flow to a
limb for
five minutes and then let it go again
for like five minutes or so
and then cut it off for five minutes
again and like that hypoxic
preconditioning seems to like fairly
notably improve work capacity
um so that's cool uh that's previously
been used in cardiac rehab stuff
and it it just seems to be kind of
making it to
exercise performance research and and
that stuff tends to be pretty positive
uh and then the one that i was positive
was [ __ ] the first time i saw ads
for it was
uh transcranial direct current
stimulation um
and like i'm still i'm still pretty
skeptical of that literature to be
honest
uh because like the the stuff i've seen
on it so
it's basically like you put a thing on
your head that has electrodes
and it stimulates uh like a particular
portion of the brain
that is supposed to improve motor output
basically um and the the research i've
seen
is kind of all over the place like where
they position the electrodes
uh a lot of them don't go into
a ton of details about like how exactly
they make sure the electrodes are
positioned
exactly right to begin with and like i'd
assume that it would need to be
um pretty precise and accurate electrode
placement
uh and like the region of the actual
brain
where the electrodes are placed over
like a lot of that is like fairly
variable but
most of the studies do do tend to have
pretty positive results
um and most of them at least don't
declare any conflicts of interest so
like
i i still there's still a lot of
a lot of skepticism in my soul about
that literature and i i think a lot of
that skepticism
comes from the original ads that i saw
for uh transcranial direct current
stimulation products and like
these products were hitting markets
before actual like
exercise research existed like it had
been tested for
some like disease states but like it
hadn't really been tested in athletes
yet
uh but people still came to market with
products and i was just like
yeah okay sure buddy um and there were
some
outrageous claims about it about this
technology
in the early ad copy so i think that's
what like really really got me skeptical
but the
the research still keeps progressing
along from multiple different ads no
declared conflicts of interest
and it does still continue to be quite
positive so i'm
uh i'm warming up to that as well and
there there was
quite a bit of research on that in 2020
yeah i mean one of the reasons that i
brought up some of my like
little fun highlights from the year of
research is because
you know i think this year one of the
lessons i learned is that
there's just no way that i'm ever gonna
get tired of this whole
research interpretation game um
and like you know whenever you do
something for a living i think you
should always be thinking like
am i going to love this forever or do i
need to like have a different plan in
mind
like am i just going to get sick of this
eventually and this year was
one of the really positives that emerged
was i just recognized like there's just
no way i could get sick of it because
you know of course there are so many
different topics that we still need to
get more information about but even just
the skills that you can continue to
develop along the way
like uh this year i got way more
into linear mix models and the
statistics
used in meta-analyses and equivalence
testing
and i already have a list of the next
topics i want to
really dive into when it comes to
research interpretation that
the next topics in terms of research
topics but also
which skills i want to develop in the
future
and you know i run through the list in
my head and i'm like dude there's no way
i'm going to live long enough
to actually get to the end of the list
and and like that
sounds morbid but that's a pretty cool
thing you know there's so much to be
learned and so many skills to be
developed there
so i'm really stoked about that and it
kind of ties into another really cool
thing about this past year which is that
you and i i mean
we work together side by side and we
look at papers and dig into them and
i think this past year we've gotten both
of us
more and more thorough and creative
about poking and prodding at research
uh that we're skeptical about you know
and i i think in the past i had a
tendency to say oh that
that seems weird i guess we'll never
know and i just shut the pdf
and move on but this year more than ever
i think both of us have said well this
seems weird
what are the implications of that you
know if this is accurate what also must
be true
and just kind of testing and poking and
prodding and getting creative about like
how can we actually determine
if this is truly weird or if we just
have a gut reaction that's not true
you know like if our skepticism is
actually justifiable and well-founded
in a quantitative sense so so that's
been a lot of fun
and i've never enjoyed puzzles i
actually hate doing puzzles
which is a problem because my girlfriend
loves them and so like
a lot of times she'll do a puzzle for
like on vacation
and i'll just like lay on the ground and
stare at the ceiling and think about
stuff
but uh i don't get whatever people get
out of puzzle
doing but it's got to be something like
this like when you
when you have skepticism like physical
puzzles physical puzzles okay yeah okay
but like and same thing like crossword
and
sudoku is that how you pronounce it i
have no idea
but you know people do like puzzles and
like brain teasers and
and stuff like that and i've never
understood the draw
of it but i think it has something to do
with this i think they're getting a
similar thing
from like what i get from poking and
prodding at research and
when you get to that moment where it all
makes sense and you're like okay i
figured out what's going on here
it's such a rewarding and fun thing like
i think i finally get it
but unfortunately i can't just like get
that from a box
you know i can't get a get out the
puzzle pieces and recreate that but
yeah this year one of the big things i
learned was that there's first of all
so much more to learn and that's an
awesome thing
and uh i don't i don't think i can ever
get tired of it
now there are also some things i learned
kind of outside of the research world
um more kind of personal stuff that i
noticed in my life
so doing something in terms of exercise
is better than nothing and that's
something i wrote a mass article about
that this past year of like you know
probably ought to do some activity even
if you're forced into a layoff and of
course with covid that became extremely
relevant
with people losing gym access but you
know this year
with my training i was forced to make
major modifications like i'm one of
those guys i love going into a
commercial gym
using all the toys there all the
different cables and you know
dumbbells and barbells and everything
else this year i had to do a lot of my
training with bands at home
and uh ooh you still need to use our new
cable setup i do
i still need to do that okay so this is
a completely
uncompensated plug uh i recently got
the like full set of stuff from uh
angles 90 grips so like those are uh
like little things that you can hang on
a bar to be able to do like rotating
grip
pull-ups uh and that that part's cool uh
i like that
um pronated and supinated pull-ups
aren't great for me i've always liked
neutral grip but these
kind of let the grip rotate uh very
ergonomic they feel good
get a good pump from them so that part's
cool but in their like full package you
can get
you it also comes with like a cable
setup
um and man that's been
so good for improving the kind of like
flexibility
of stuff i can do in a home gym uh all
of the
equipment itself works well if you have
a little bit of creativity and ingenuity
you can set up
just about any exercise that you would
want to
um and yeah so so for an affordable
thing to really
um expand what you can accomplish in a
home gym
both the grippers like the angle 90s
grips themselves and just like the cable
setup you can buy from them as well
uh strongly strongly recommend and like
i said that that's a completely
uncompensated endorsement i have no
partnership with them whatsoever
uh but that that has definitely been the
coolest and best addition i've made to
my home gym
since i've had a home gym it's uh it's
pretty awesome
yeah i'm looking forward to trying that
out but so this past year had to make
serious modifications and i did have
that point where i was like should i
even bother
you know like this isn't the way i enjoy
training so like maybe i just say screw
it and you know
do other stuff but i was really amazed
you know i had seen the research on it
and i knew
even with low volumes if you get some
solid resistance training work
in you can maintain a lot of your gains
pretty effectively i
understood that from the research but i
was still blown away from a practical
application standpoint this year
i barely trained this year like in terms
of what i would consider
training you know heavy stuff breaking a
sweat
you know really pushing it did some band
work did some pull-up stuff push-up
stuff
and i was absolutely amazed and thrilled
at how much i was able to maintain
muscle mass
body composition and to some extent
strength the strength dropped off a
little bit but i have done some
heavier workouts in your home gym and
after like a couple weeks of hitting the
heavy stuff it's back
like not fully but it comes back quick
so i was really
uh pleasantly surprised at kind of
learning that lesson practically
speaking not just relying on the
literature but
it's amazing how much better it is to do
something than nothing and it's amazing
how much you can preserve with low
training volumes
another training thing i learned this
year is
you know i've been blaming exercise way
too much for how much my
my hip hurts i've got a bum hip it's
largely due to my wrestling career
wrestling i love the sport but like if
you look at what a wrestling stance is
supposed to be
it's like staggered feet hips are high
shoulders are low you're crouched over
it ain't great
like it's not a good stance to be in for
a large percentage of your life it's not
very comfortable so
i had some lower back issues after my
wrestling career had some hip issues
part of that's on me
i wasn't that good i'm sure i could have
i probably could have avoided that if i
was just better at doing what i was
supposed to be doing
but anyway i got into that mode i mean
i've been training consistently since i
was like 12
up until this year where i had to make
major modifications
been doing heavy lower body stuff since
i was like 12.
and i just kind of assumed like uh yeah
my weight training stuff is
really contributing to a lot of my hip
and lower back pain
and if i just didn't do heavy lower body
stuff for like a month i'm sure it would
clear
up but i don't want to do that so i'll
just keep pushing through it
well you know this year i was forced to
really drastically
change my lower body training for
certain periods of time
and the bad news is nothing got better
but the good news is nothing got better
which means like it doesn't seem to
matter
if i'm doing the training i love or not
like i'm gonna have to work around this
no matter what
and that might seem like bad news but to
me that's good news like
it's just a thing that i can continue to
work around it's not debilitating
it's not a major issue and this really
means like i don't have to feel guilty
about going in and doing the lower body
stuff i like to do you know once i'm
able to do that more consistently
i don't have to feel like i'm you know
screwing myself
over and causing all this hip and back
pain because like that stuff just
appears to be there regardless so
i should probably deal with that
eventually i'm sure i will but
i actually view that as kind of good
news that my back and hip didn't really
get much better when i ceased
heavy lower body training one thing i
know i noticed this year
thing i learned is that i feel like
absolute horseshit
when my sleep hygiene is bad and my
sleep and wake cycle is
out of whack one of the things i really
did poorly this year is manage my
sleep and wake times did some really
late nights that turned into really late
mornings that turned into really
shortened days that turned into some
really weird stuff
my sleep and wake cycle was totally
irregular
so even when i was getting you know six
seven eight hours of sleep
the fact that that sleep window kept
shifting so much
day over day week over week for me
personally i just feel way worse
when i do that and i feel like even when
i get enough sleep i struggle to focus
quite as well
i feel like cognitively i'm not very
sharp when i'm just
breaking every rule associated with
circadian biology which like
probably not a good idea like that that
stuff's not pseudoscience it actually
exists
so um that's an important thing i
learned that i'm gonna act on this year
i also learned that having a little bit
of structure in my schedule is good
like having no structure at all in my
schedule is bad
i lose time because i'm inefficient at
the same time
having too much structure in my schedule
is bad if i say like between the hours
of 9 a.m and 11 a.m
i only do this single task on a day
where i don't feel like doing that task
at that time
i misuse the time you know what i mean
so it
this upcoming year i really want to
focus on getting a balance
of having flexible
structure in my day where there are
certain chunks of time where i do
certain things but there's at least some
choice involved
so if i you know get to my desk and it's
supposed to be writing time and i feel
like cranking out emails
fine we'll make a quick swap but we
won't be inefficient you know what i
mean
one other thing that i learned i didn't
really learn it but i reinforced it so
like many this year i spent a little bit
more alone time
relative to other years and i'm
pretty i don't know i've heard people
use terms when
when they talk about being an introvert
or an extrovert
apparently there's like a bunch of other
categories i don't understand
i've never looked into it but i think
i'm introverted in the sense that like
i really enjoy my alone time and
solitude
and if i do socialize it's not that i
don't enjoy it but it drains me of
energy
like i can't talk for that long you've
seen
sometimes with mass we'll have three or
four hour skype calls
dude by the end of them i'm like i i'd
probably
look and feel like i just wish i was
dead like i'm so
drained of energy and i'm like dude i
cannot keep going
so uh i think that might just be a skype
thing though
i think it's in person too though like
you've probably noticed that like
when we do like family dinner after like
three hours of actually
interacting with people i do check out
for like 30 minutes
i don't know if you've noticed but like
aya has noticed no no yeah
i'm just saying like i think uh i think
like video chatting exacerbates that
because i'm yeah
i'm very extroverted but i'm
dude after like two hours on any sort of
video chat service i'm just [ __ ]
done yeah yeah i mean that it is much
more tedious when you're
doing it virtually but anyway this year
i just kind of
relearned or i guess reinforced how much
i love
solitude and that i have a really short
but rechargeable battery life when it
comes to continuous
social interaction so that's been a
valuable thing to learn about myself
i've actually been able to kind of
use that and kind of plan like okay if i
know i need to interact at this time
i'm gonna kind of figure out how to
structure my day so i don't go into that
already burnt out because it's just not
fun or pleasant for anybody involved if
you're supposed to be
fun and interacting and stuff and you're
just like completely tapped out for
for that kind of energy so yeah that's
the stuff i learned and
you know we'll talk about goals later
but uh greg 2020 what'd you learn
yeah so uh let me start by saying
that uh it was very smart of treks to
make this a fireside chat episode which
uh again as we've established is
supposed to be
very light good vibes only
because if i was being completely honest
and transparent here
this section would be pretty dark and
nihilistic
um but i'll i'll pretend like it's not
for the purposes of this episode uh so
anyway
it's show business you gotta give the
people what they want yeah absolutely
um so let me start by saying that i'm
actually fairly proud of how i've done
this year
overall which is pretty rare uh because
my internal dialogue tends to be
fairly dark and my self-concept tends to
be pretty low
but yeah my my habitual problems
have you know ever since i was a wee lad
are using time poorly um
working too much and not spending enough
time with people who matter to me
not sleeping enough and uh making stupid
decisions in my training
uh that that wind up getting me hurt and
then
having to take major time off of
training um
and uh yeah i still have plenty of room
to improve in all of those areas but
they did
like every single one of them overall
did go better in 2021
than in years past uh so still plenty of
room to improve but
uh definite progress which is nice and
quite frankly kind of surprising
um because i'm not generally one for for
the whole personal growth thing
um so some things that i think have
contributed to that
uh are um much like trex brought up i've
kept a far
more normal schedule this year than i
have in years past
um i'll still occasionally uh more than
occasionally
um i'll still let my circadian rhythm
get
way out of whack but way less in 2020
than in previous years
um you know i've kept more normal
working hours
i have slept a larger proportion of
nights
uh than normal uh way fewer all-nighters
and
and i think that um that's been
i mean that's been huge for me that's
that's definitely contributed to uh
improving productivity uh another thing
that helped me a ton
is taking time completely off
so um like just kind of the way i was
raised
is you don't take time off when you have
work to do
and that worked really really well
through childhood that worked
really well in college that worked
really well
when i was someone else's employee uh
and you know i had working hours that
worked
really poorly when i started my own
business uh
because there is virtually an infinite
to-do list
at all times and when you mark something
off something else gets added
there there are always things you can do
and so
you know this mindset that had
previously been
very very good and productive became
incredibly counterproductive because i'd
wind up working way too much
and you know as you work more
your efficiency gets worse and worse uh
and then i'd also
like have this sense of guilt about
taking time
completely off because i was just like
you know the way my life has always
worked up to this point is if i have
things on my to-do list
i shouldn't take a break i shouldn't
take time off uh
and then i'd like feel guilty about
doing things that weren't working um and
that uh
that really wasn't good um
see i i've really been working on
kind of my mental space around time off
and focusing
on you know just saying like hey there's
still things on my to-do list but i got
enough done today
like i can not think about work this
evening
be fully in the moment fully present not
have to feel guilty
uh about spending time with my wife or
people i care about or
you know just doing something for me um
that's not work so that's uh i think
that
that was good for my productivity i
worked
less this year than previous years and
still got just as much done
so that was a big plus uh and i ended up
being able to spend
a lot more meaningful meaningful time
with people i care about
um how long have you been working for
yourself
so like when did you make that
transition from
you know your work is given to you yeah
from people to
now it's completely on you so it came in
stages i mean i i started making
some money coaching in 2012.
um but i uh my own businesses weren't
my primary source of income until
i think early 2015 so yeah it's uh
it's been about five years uh in the
first
the first four years of owning a
business were very rewarding and also
very bad for my mental health
and uh yeah so i i'm i'm starting to get
a better handle
on how to approach all of that
yeah because two things jumped out to me
as you were talking about some of these
lessons learned
uh first of all i still don't understand
how we're friends
um you know you mentioned that your
self-concept is pretty negative your
internal dialogue is pretty
uh pretty dark pretty morbid and mine is
two
you would think that our presence in the
same room would be just
catastrophically toxic but you seem to
have a much different
reaction like the things going on in our
heads are quite similar but the way we
react to them are
polar opposites so i mean this is what i
let's just go for it [ __ ] it so this is
what i removed from
uh from the original outline when oh and
i was glad you removed it so now i feel
terrible no it'll be fine like i think
this is
a a useful reframing so um
in in the original version of the
outline that trek sent to me
there was you know a phrase at the top
that shows up at the top of all of our
fireside chat outlines
that was good vibes only in like 14
point font
and i i put my outline in of the stuff i
wanted to talk about
and part of that was like kind of my
mindset around things
uh and then i pulled the outline back up
a day later
and uh good vibes only was now increased
to 24 point font
and highlighted uh and i i looked
through my outline and i was like okay
yep this is probably what
what trex wants me to amend uh
i wasn't gonna make you but i just
wanted to say like hey
on the front end going into this like
you know no i i i can take a hint
uh but anyway no so i think the reason
we process
uh dark thoughts
very differently is like i've talked
about this on the podcast before and i
don't think people believe me but i'm
uh i'm brutally nihilistic
um and so like and also like i don't
think
i don't think free will exist like i
think the world is deterministic
i don't yeah i think that uh
your your moment-to-moment experience is
the result of like
chemical processes in your brain that
are all deterministic like i don't
see a i i don't see an avenue
through which uh free will
and like true robust human agency
can exist uh so yeah like my
moment-to-moment experience is that i
have free will but i think that's
uh a very intricate illusion
and so like i've uh i've internalized
that sense of of nihilism
more and more with each passing year and
honestly it's been great for my mental
state
um because like i don't know
uh you know i i'm just kind of along for
the ride you know i'm uh
kind of just watching everything play
out before me like a very very engaging
and engrossing movie
and uh you know like
yeah the movie's good the movie's bad i
don't have any control over it either
way
so uh may as well just like sit back and
enjoy it
well i mean that does make sense because
like with you know the way that i always
uh
i i tend to think about things and be
like oh there's a lot of bad things and
then i'll verbalize them
and i guess if your inner monologue was
far more positive than mine
then that would really be devastating to
the likelihood of us being friends right
you'd have to shut it down you'd be like
no trex it can't all be this bad no i i
think a lot of our friendship
is based on like mutually validating
the worst and darkest impulses we both
have
yeah well that's that's terrific yeah
you'll love to see it
um the other thing i noticed when you
were talking
the reason i asked like when did you
start doing this yeah i've been doing
this for two years now
and what you're describing is like the
bad stuff you used to do in time
in terms of your time management your
sleep schedule things like that
those are just new habits that that i
adopted the day i started doing this
stuff
and so uh it is nice uh to see that you
did all that stuff have been there and
that you're noticing
some pretty profound improvements now
that you have
worked on that yeah and you have a more
normal schedule you're more
mindful about taking actual time off so
that's really encouraging to see first
of all that
i feel like most of the people we talk
to that have gone their own way and done
their own thing
had those couple years there where they
just overworked didn't take any time off
and it just
generally wasn't positive so hopefully i
can join
you and next year when we record this i
can say hey
uh i improved that a lot and boy do i
love it but so here
here's another thing that i guess it is
worth pointing out
um yeah so if if you're listening to
this
and you have like recently started a
business and you're trying to get it off
the ground or like you know maybe you
started a business a year or two ago and
like
it's it's not quite paying the bills
quite as well as
as you want to yet uh i don't view
myself as like a business guru by any
sense but i
i definitely i think it would probably
not be great
um to listen to this conversation
as kind of like generalized advice about
getting a business off the ground
because like
at this point we have the luxury of
stronger by science and mass both being
like
pretty pretty well established
businesses um
very good point i don't think the early
part of my career
would have gone as well uh if i didn't
have those
very deeply ingrained workaholic
tendencies um
like and again don't take that as a
recommendation because like there are
certainly people who have successful
businesses that didn't
like completely work themselves into the
ground to get there but
for me personally if i didn't
uh if i
only worked the amount that was healthy
uh i don't think
stronger by science would have gotten to
where it currently is
um so anyway i mean like
work-life balance is a big thing i am
definitely not the person to ask about
it because i
have i previously had horrendously bad
work-life balance
and now i just kind of have like
garden-variety bad work-life balance
um so yeah i mean you know
if if you own your own business and
it could be better if you worked more
that's a question to ask yourself like
what would you have to sacrifice for
you to get more work in your business
and for the business to go better and
like
is that worth it to you in hindsight
honestly like
it's hard for me to say because i love
what i currently do but also
i i feel like i more or less mortgaged
my mid-20s to get here
uh and i hear your mid-20s are supposed
to be pretty good
so um yeah i don't know uh do with that
which you will
i'm laughing because i've had this
conversation i've talked to a lot of
people who are about to start grad
school
and who want to do you know six years of
it masters phd all together
and they asked me like well what were
your work habits like as a grad
student and what's so funny about that
so yeah greg saw me in my natural
habitat
uh he did his masters toward the tail
end of my phd
and his laughter indicates dude i worked
a lot
like i'm not an exceptional talent or an
exceptional researcher but
i was a lot more productive than most
and that was a very literal
exchange of my time and happiness for
research productivity
you know and i've had this same
conversation with people who are about
to enter grad school and they say well
how much
should i work and i'll go well i don't
know but i worked an obscene amount that
was unsustainable
and then at the end of it i was met with
a number of
remarkable opportunities and they say
well was it
worth it and i'm like i don't know like
i think so like i i wouldn't redo it
because like
the opportunities i had on the other
side were remarkable it's kind of like
you were saying with
setting up a business if you're able to
get it to a point where you're like okay
it's established and it's working the
way i want it to
you look back and you're like well i
can't say i regret
you know putting in all that time and
effort and having those questionable
pretty intense work habits um so it's
it's yeah it's it's a trade-off and the
the cost-benefit
uh analysis is kind of subjective yeah
and honestly if someone
tries to confidently tell you that they
know what that cost benefit analysis is
they're full of [ __ ]
yeah cause the thing is like i looking
back on it i do feel like
pretty decent about the the choices i
made
um but at the same time like i can't
test the counter factual
you know what i mean exactly like i
can't go back and do it differently to
know if
i mean i i feel like i can stay pretty
confidently i definitely could have been
happier in the moment if i did things
differently
uh would would i be would i be happier
now like
i don't know maybe maybe not uh it's
hard to say i i think that there is
too much glorification of like
quote-unquote rise and grind culture
and the other thing i'll say is like um
one of the risks that i don't think
is discussed enough is like
the fact that it might not work out you
know
so i mean we're we're on the other this
is gone
this is not a good vibes only episode i
don't care it's
i think it's decent yeah [ __ ] it um but
yeah so i mean like
it it worked out for me like it's paid
off the business is going well um
hopefully it continues to do so i have a
good sense of ownership over it
um and yeah i mean like i feel
pretty good about where my life
currently is but the thing is like
a i don't want to throw a number out
there
but like a good chunk of attempts at
starting a business fail
um and so i mean like i feel like i can
confidently say
if i went through you know what what i
went through from
22 to 27 28
uh and the business never did get off
the ground
and you know i i more or less just like
mortgaged my early 20s
for you know a shot that didn't pan out
and then i still just like went back to
work for someone else and like
especially if i would have wound up
going into debt like trying to
trying to make the business work i feel
like i wouldn't look back on that fondly
at all
and so i mean like yeah that's uh that's
a distinct possibility as well like i
you know do what you want to do with
your life i don't want to try to
persuade or dissuade you from doing
anything
um i don't know i i'm
i think i'm mostly saying this for
myself i guess
uh and also to warn you if uh
if someone's saying like hey this is
what i did here the sacrifices i
i made um you know it worked out well
for me or it didn't work out well for me
don't don't necessarily assume that
that's like a generalizable statement
and also keep the bias in mind
that most of the people that you're
going to be hearing
business advice from are from people
whose business has worked out uh you
don't hear from the people who didn't
uh and so i mean like that's that's a
side of the calculus that you you rarely
hear discussed and
rarely hear perspectives on so i'm
smiling because i'm just gonna swing
so hard for the fences here with just
the a morbid home run
like i know that i said good vibes only
but
i'm just going for it i feel like it's
like i'm gonna one-up you so hard here
so just to reiterate i made a lot of
sacrifices in grad school i
certainly could have had a more pleasant
six years if i worked less
but i i don't regret it because i was i
came out of it with remarkable
opportunities which which was awesome
so i like where i'm at and it was
totally worth it
however as you know
about five and a half years into that
six year period
i received a pretty confident cancer
diagnosis
and it if it was
true then i i actually had like a pretty
advanced case because like i had had the
symptoms i was reporting for like
18 months yeah and like a
doctor told me like listen we need to
run the test but like
you got it you know like and so like i
mean they kept the place open late so
they could get the tests in that day so
that we could go ahead and get started
on treatment
you know like let's take the weekend and
then let's get started yeah
well it turns out that that diagnosis
was not accurate
i did not have cancer fortunately but
like
literally i can tell you i walked out of
that office and i sat in my car and i
said
none of that [ __ ] was worth it i regret
100
of it so like like you said the cost
benefits stuff like
a lot of it is calculated purely in
hindsight based on like how it turns out
and a lot of it's calculated uh based on
like looking ahead
you know uh like not to cut you off too
hard but like
you know i'm 29 now business is going
well
uh i'm pretty happy with my life and so
i you know i'm
anticipating that uh that will more or
less be the case for the rest of my
working life
but the thing is uh i feel like i can
say this like
if i uh went to the grocery store
tonight and got in a car wreck and died
uh and someone could like ask me you
know
right before i drew my last breath was
it all worth it [ __ ] no
are you kidding me because the thing is
like the thought is like
you know you're gonna uh spend time
doing something and like hopefully it
pays off
in the long run but like if there's no
long run
uh yeah you know that the calculus
completely changes
you know if i could add one more regret
to my list of regrets
it would be bringing up this
conversation i regret that mightily so
let's get back to the very enthusiastic
things
things that you learned this past year
uh i mean the next one's
not like super optimistic um but
but on on the research side of things
and and the research interpretation game
i would largely echo eric saltz
um i think i've expanded my skills quite
a bit
uh i think i've also gotten more jaded
about the scientific publishing process
we've talked about some of those reasons
on the podcast um
there there was another saga that's been
playing out behind the scenes as well
that i'm not currently at liberty to
talk about but i've uh
i've got a good story for you guys at
some point once uh
when something is resolved so i'll throw
that out as a teaser
listen to all of the episodes in 2020
and 2021
to figure out when when i can actually
tell that story
um on the training front i've
really embraced rep based progression uh
and it's worked out really really well
for me so for
for most of this year the way i've set
my training up
is i'll pick a movement and uh you know
ideally it's it's something that i can
do for
like a three to five rep max to start
with
and then uh in my training sessions like
the the main working set i do is just
trying to beat
my old rep pr and the thing is like
that has worked really really well for
me in the past
um but i've gotten away from it for a
couple reasons
the biggest reason is like i don't love
it i guess
um i i really i love doing heavy singles
uh there is a reason i'm a power lifter
um
but uh like looking back at past
training logs
generally i have had a lot of success
with the rep based progressions and i
think one of the reasons
for that is if you're not making
progress particularly quickly anymore
in your training career which like i'm
not because i've been doing this for a
long time
it it's generally um
i find at least it's generally easier
to add a rep and have it feel like
real tangible progress than
to add more weight to the bar at least
like an amount of weight that
like i personally care about so for
like for for pressing exercises like i
don't care about
two and a halfs and fives like you know
unless i can put some more tens on the
bar
25s like i'm like yeah who cares
whatever uh and for lower body stuff
i pretty much only work with like plates
and 25s
because like for me personally i feel
like okay if i hit a heavy triple
at uh like 5.85
on deadlift or something like that and
next week i come in and i do
590. like to me that doesn't feel like
progress
i know intellectually it is um
but you know it's one of those things
we're like uh whatever like
you can get in your head like maybe the
585 was easy
but the 590 was like actually quite hard
it's like oh but but it's only five
pounds
uh so maybe i i actually regressed but i
was still able to knock out that triple
you know like that that's something that
can get in my head
um and so like the reason i i tend to
make like pretty big weight jumps is
like those are the jumps where i feel
like okay like
if i can knock this out i have
definitely gotten stronger
unambiguously and the thing with
rep-based progressions is
is it's not that hard to do like it's
way easier to add
a rep to an exercise than like 20 or 50
pounds to the bar
um but i also feel like okay if i got
six reps last time and the last one was
a grinder and i got seven reps this time
that is
like actual real progress that i can be
confident in
um so so like psychologically it's been
working pretty well for me
uh physiologically it's been working
pretty well for me um
like i've i think i'm at or very close
to my all-time strongest which
is definitely a good feeling um
so yeah deal with that what you will
it's been working out well for me
another thing that i've that i
found it's not like a new discovery i
guess but one of the things that was
really
reinforced for me on on the training
side of things this year
is that for me doing what i call
feel good work is just as important for
me as my main training sessions
so uh and especially for lower body
stuff
so if between squat and deadlift
workouts i can
you know like carve out about an hour
or so once and ideally twice uh
to do some static stretching some
lacrosse ball rolling on my hips
some split squats some single leg rdl
some side bends
some like really really long low
weight paul squats some calf raises some
jefferson curls stuff like that
um it just makes everything go better
that that i don't want to state this as
a generalizable thing because i know
like
pt and like injury folks would get mad
at me but like it's a fireside chat you
can say whatever you want okay
when i personally do stuff like that i
don't hurt my back
and when i don't do stuff like that i do
hurt my back
and i've i've experienced both of these
things
enough times that i feel like for myself
i can draw that inference
not not trying to generalize it to
anyone else but that's what i've
observed for myself
um so so yeah it keeps me healthy keeps
me feeling good
and also it seems to improve progress um
like when i'm consistently doing stuff
like that
i feel good and i get stronger and when
i don't do that stuff
uh i plateau i stall and i get hurt
so that's i mean like
that process has repeated enough times
that for me
i can take that as a fact uh and it's
it's something i
i have to do and i've been much more
consistent doing stuff like that this
year than previous years
um another another big
area of personal growth for me as
someone who works online
is uh improving it not getting sucked
into arguments
so like i used to be so bad about this i
like when i first started working online
i'd get sucked into arguments on
facebook all the time
and still like every day people will tag
me in threads
where the person tagging me knows that i
will disagree with whatever was posted
and they're like hoping that i'm going
to argue with the person who made the
post
uh or i'll like get an email that's like
hey want to come on a podcast and debate
someone
uh or like someone will link me a thread
where someone's like
talking [ __ ] or like misinterpreting
something i've wrote
saying like yeah don't you want to set
them straight and like
no i don't i used to always engage with
stuff like that
um and looking back at it
every single time over in the last like
five six years every single time that
i've taken the bait
and engaged in something like that
regardless of how the discussion ends up
going i always look back on it as a
waste of time
i've i've never i've never taken the
debate and looked back and said ah yes
that was a good use of time and i have
no regrets about doing it
uh and so like i've
really improved this year uh on not
taking the bait
and that that has to have reclaimed like
dozens of productive hours in my life uh
and so like yeah i'm uh i'm very proud
of myself
for not engaging online uh and then the
last thing i have here is
um i've got i mean if you follow me on
instagram you know this but i've gotten
way more into cooking and baking
and that's also been really great for me
so it's
it's a fun hobby i like doing it and
it's something
that i like to be able to do for family
and friends
the one thing worth noting if you do see
my cooking
instagram posts and instagram stories
and you're just like jesus christ
like how does how does greg eat like
that all the time
i don't uh i do not make any of that
stuff for myself
so um that's
exclusively stuff that i make for
friends and family
and uh that's that's good for me
because um
like like we've mentioned like three
times before on this episode already
i do kind of have like self-worth issues
and
for me like i i i do still feel guilty
when i do
take time completely for myself
uh and and have like completely
like greg focused hobbies i guess and
like
that's what lifting is you know like i i
do it for myself
it feels good i don't do it for anyone
else um
but then i feel like kind of guilty if i
invest way too much time in training
because
you know that's time that i could be
spending like more productively or doing
something
nice for someone else and so with
cooking it's something that i
really really enjoy doing um but i i can
do it like
to make other people happy and to be
able to give them something
so it's probably my only hobby that i
have like
not even a kernel of guilt associated
with
uh and it's uh it's been good to have a
hobby like that
all right good stuff all right now we're
gonna shift gears a little bit and talk
about some goals
for the upcoming year so now we're
looking forward rather than backward
and i'm gonna go quick through mine um
because i i love the audience and i'm
sure they love me
but i don't think anyone wants to hear
me talk about me for
you know 30 minutes so the reason i want
to share these is
i think it can be kind of instructive
like maybe it gives you a good idea
about how to
reframe some of your own goals or maybe
you hear a goal and you're like oh that
might actually work out well for me so
um what i'm doing this year is really
just focusing on building better habits
and you know it's tough because i'm i'm
at a crossroads with some of these goals
because
you know they always talk about a smart
goal where you want it to be pretty
specific
and quantifiable whenever possible but
when you talk about habit building
one of the terms that comes up a lot is
friction right you want to
add more friction between you and the
habits you're trying to stop doing
and you want to reduce the friction
between you and the habits that you want
to develop
you know you want to make it easier on
yourself and put yourself
in a setting in an environment where
you're likely to succeed so
it's a delicate balance you're going to
see that some of my goals are
intentionally less quantifiable than
they could be or less quantified than
they could be
so that'll make sense as i go through
them but that's one of my big
overarching themes is i'm trying to
focus more on building better habits
rather than just like hitting specific
metrics
and another thing is that i'm trying to
focus on adding good things to my life
instead of
avoiding bad things or removing bad
things um
so approach versus avoidance goals
absolutely
so uh yeah so one of the things i'm
doing is i'm waking up at the same time
every day
and i already started applying all these
goals uh
as of like december 30th not because i
think you know
sometimes around new year's like two
days before everybody says oh you got to
start it now or else you're not
hardcore and intense and you don't care
enough and you're never going to succeed
with it
that's not the case but when i put these
goals down on paper i noticed that they
were just things that made me feel so
much better and i was like
i really want to do all that now because
like i want to feel good
so waking up at the same time every day
and preferably close to sunrise
so if i wake up at the same time every
day that's going to ensure that i go to
bed at a pretty similar time because
i know me i am not going to cut my sleep
short like i'm not gonna stay up till
three and force myself to wake up at 7
30. it's not gonna happen i will get
myself to bed
um so i know that by waking up at the
same
time every day it's gonna cause me to go
to bed at approximately the same time
every night and get a more consistent
pattern there
and the reason i'm waking up around
sunrise is i'm really trying to maximize
my exposure to sunlight
just because it makes me feel better
like it's not good for me to wake up at
noon and then the sun goes down at like
5 15 and i'm just like well the sun
never came out today
i didn't experience it you know so just
sitting in my office with the window
open enjoying the sunlight
it does a lot for me in terms of
productivity and focus and just
psychologically
i feel so much better and then the
circadian aspects of just having that
normal sleep and wake schedule
is a really beautiful thing one of the
things i'm doing to make this
work is so
my worst habit one of the habits that
fortunately i haven't done it in
you know about a week now it makes me
sick to think that i do this and i just
keep doing it uh
until now i have a really bad habit
where i'll wake up
and pick up my phone and just waste time
on my phone while i'm still in bed
and it's the worst habit and i i just
had so much trouble shaking it so
what i'm doing to avoid that and to have
a consistent wake time
phone alarm every single morning even if
i don't have to
really use it just put the phone alarm
on and put the phone
way across across the room i know some
people that's still not enough friction
and they'll go and turn it off and get
back in bed but for me if i'm getting up
and i'm going to the phone and i'm
turning the alarm off i'm up
and i can avoid that awful time suck of
just laying in bed with my phone
and i'm up for the day and it's all good
um
and so another thing i'm doing outside
of the the realm of sleep and stuff
trying to stay more hydrated so i'm
drinking at least two liters
specifically of just
water per day and trying to drink more
tea at night
and what i find is if i accomplish both
of those things then
i'll hit my total fluid goal for the day
when you combine up my coffee in the
morning and
fluids from food and stuff like that is
that decaf tea
yes yeah that's a good point decaf tea
at night
so two a few like indirect effects of
this uh
first of all i feel way better when i'm
consistently hydrated
um but i drink probably a little more
alcohol than i should
um and like don't send for help it's
fine like it's just like
i don't know i'm bored like i've been
quarantined for nine months you know or
isolated
so like where i normally would have like
maybe three drinks in a week
now it's like you know maybe i'll have a
drink a night sometimes two
and it's just like a little bit more
than i should drink based on
the evidence available i think and i
feel a little bit crummy if i start to
get to like
two or three drinks like the next
morning i'm not quite as sharp
i don't sleep as well so like i'm trying
to reduce my alcohol intake not because
it's like a huge issue but again it's
just about feeling better
um and so what i notice is if i'm
drinking two liters of water throughout
the day and i'm drinking tea at night
some of that kind of boredom related
alcohol intake just because i like beer
and bourbon
it just gets displaced because there's
so many other fluids that i'm like oh i
better drink this i better drink that
um another unintended or i guess
secondary consequence
of drinking more water and tea is i'm
less likely to over consume caffeine
so i'm less likely because i have all
these other fluids i gotta get in
to make a second thing of coffee every
time i do it i feel like crap and i
sleep poorly that night and i just keep
doing it
like i keep making more coffee and i
shouldn't no i i noticed that as well
i used to i used to be really bad about
consuming way too much caffeine like i'd
have
three or four or five very heavily
caffeinated beverages a day
uh and and recently like i've i've cut
back to two and i think that works
pretty well for me and and one of the
things i would notice is like
uh midday energy levels would really
start dropping i'd start feeling kind of
blah and be like
okay i i need more caffeine and then i
drink more caffeine and be like ah
nope still don't feel better uh and then
i chug some water and be like okay i
feel pretty good now
um but like that third caffeinated
beverage was completely unnecessary like
if i just drink water like that's what
my body was calling out for
uh and so yeah now i i start my my
morning with two caffeinated beverages
switch to water and that's uh
it hasn't negatively impacted my energy
levels and and has been improving my
sleep quality so
big co-sign on that goal yeah and
another benefit of these fluid related
goals so like
my morning looks totally different now i
wake up get the alarm off get the coffee
brewing
and i start drinking some of my two
liters of water for the day
and it's great because i used to wake up
and the first thing i did was like
waste time on my phone in bed and then
be like
you suck eric but now i wake up i go
you know make some progress on my fluid
goal for the day and i feel like within
the first 15 minutes of waking up i'm
already being productive
and checking stuff off the list like it
actually has been a really big boost for
my morning mindset which i'm not gonna
get into a bunch of like feel-good
nonsense but like for me that that's a
nice thing
um another thing i'm looking for uh in
this this upcoming year
is at least 30 minutes of structured
exercise every day
it doesn't matter what but like the gift
and the curse of what we do is i think
we both love it
and it's very easy to keep working
instead of doing exercise on any given
day
and if i leave any wiggle room and say
i'm going to work out four times this
week
i'll skip my exercise like the first
three days of the week you know because
i'll be like oh no
there's other days where i'll work out
but i just find that i'm skipping too
much stuff
it's just not good so every day 30
minutes of something
could be you know stretching and foam
rolling could be cardio could be lifting
could be
a million things but 30 minutes or
something
um and and that's been going really well
and again it's just one more thing that
you check it off the list
and you feel really good about it like i
feel better when i'm consistently
exercising
another one i'm looking for is having
two high fiber meals per day
now i could track that precisely and say
no the goal is you know 40 grams of
fiber a day
but i wanted to reduce the friction
because like just the
the mechanical process of tracking and
making myself get
way more into nutrition tracking which
i'm currently not doing just based on my
goals and where i'm at
it's too much friction to put in the
goal i wouldn't have accomplished it
because the
process of trying to meet the goal would
have been really off-putting at this
point in time
so two high-fiber meals per day easy i
could quantify that better but
i think that's a nice low friction thing
and the reason i'm doing it is
i feel better on a high fiber diet and
it causes me to seek out some more
diverse foods into my diet so i get more
grains i get more vegetables and i just
feel really solid
and then the final thing here is unless
i'm on vacation or unless i'm doing my
big coaching check-in days which are
very very busy
uh in the morning two hours of riding no
interruptions whatsoever
we have a lot of projects going on at
any given time and we always have stuff
to be writing
and it's if you don't make the time for
it in structured blocks it's easy to get
into that cycle of
i'll push it off till the evening i'll
start at 8 pm and then it's 3am and
you're like oh crap i did it again
right and now your sleep schedule is
totally jacked up so it just has to it
just has to happen a two-hour chunk of
the day
that cannot be touched that is purely
for writing no email no social media
nothing else
just writing because we got a lot of
writing to do greg i don't know if
anybody told you but uh
we got a lot of stuff to do oh lindsay's
gonna tell us
tomorrow yeah when we have our our
yearly review meeting
yeah that's true so one of the big
things this year
when it comes to productivity is just
picking chunks of time to
truly focus and picking chunks of time
to really let loose and take actual time
off
and just kind of simplify things when
i'm writing
don't have the email tab up and then you
get an email and the little
number in the parentheses goes up and
then you're side tracked
none of that crap it's just got to stop
and that's it
sounds good so i i'm not going to
talk too much about my like process
goals
uh that much because honestly a lot of
it would just be
reiterating a lot of the same things you
said uh and i'm sure the audience
doesn't want to hear the same stuff
twice
so in terms of just like other random
goals i have this year
um so i've been
in pursuit of several lifting numbers
for a hot minute
uh that's a 800 pound squat 500 pound
bench and 800 pound deadlift
i feel really really good
about the squat number this year as long
as i can stay healthy
um i i think i'm hopefully not
too many months off of that uh the bench
goal i think should also be
doable this year uh we'll see on that
um there's a chance that i'll just
not do the bench because like frankly i
don't care
we've talked about this before i hate
bench i'm so close to 500 that i'm just
like
[ __ ] it like i've done 485 i should be
able to get over that hump
but i don't know like i'm i'm on a very
squat focused cycle now
uh after that i'll switch to bench and
there is a chance in a couple months
i'll just be like [ __ ] this i hate
benching
i don't actually ever have to binge 500
i'll still be able to
to live with myself and sleep at night
so anyway
that may or may not happen this year and
then depending how much
actual focus i i end up putting on bench
we'll see on deadlift
um because that that's the third one
i'll get around to
it's the one that i'm i'm the farthest
off of my best pull
is 735 so i do have a considerable
amount of work to do there
uh but but lifting wise those are are
still my goals
rolling into 2021. do you realize how
many people
you just pissed off by saying like i
guess i might as well do
500 like on the bench like
uh just like it's like well i mean you
might as well while you're here you know
well no because like i know i'm upset on
one hand
i do now understand how that probably
came off
uh i i view it less in terms of like
the actual numbers i'm throwing out
there and more just in terms of like
any goal that you feel like you probably
should do but aren't like particularly
invested in doing i guess yeah um
i don't know uh yeah whatever
yeah [ __ ] it i i've already ruined this
episode i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
push ahead
uh anyway those are my lifting goals um
in terms of uh like business stuff
my my biggest goal this year is to get
more free content on the website
um so going back to the theme of
having structure being good uh
a couple of the things that have helped
my productivity a lot
are having mass to put out every month
because i am going to write three
articles for that
uh and doing the podcast consistently
because
you know i have to learn things and
outline episodes and talk about things
um so we we have been really
consistently getting content
out there but the free stuff has mostly
been audio and the written stuff has
has mostly been paywalled uh and quite
frankly
i just like putting out free written
content that's
that is the thing that i think i get the
most
joy from uh because i personally like
written content way more than audio
content
uh and i i like putting stuff out there
for free
so um yeah that's
that's the biggest thing i want to
accomplish business-wise this year just
just make more time to get more free
articles out um
and yeah so that's oh another thing this
year
uh worth noting is we we finally got the
updated version of the stronger by
science lifting programs out
and i spent a lot of time this year uh
pretty massively upgrading those so
there were
i think three spreadsheets when when it
initially launched and now there's like
14 spreadsheets in that bundle uh
really good value just throwing that out
there but a lot of work went towards
that
this year and i think that that's a
pretty set product now i don't
foresee myself continuing to to update
that very much
um so that that should unlock quite a
bit of time to write
and then for kind of like personal stuff
i guess like my biggest my biggest goal
this year is to continue
improving at using my time well um so
spending time on
big things that will matter for the
business not getting
as sucked into minutia on a day-to-day
basis
um fully relaxing when i do have time to
take time off and
and taking time for myself uh spending
more quality time with my wife
and my friends and my family um
because yeah i mean like whenever i
look back at like good memories and
things that
have happened in my life it's it's
generally when i'm spending quality time
with people i care about
um see i i want to be even more
intentional about
making more time for that this year good
stuff well
that's pretty much what we wanted to
cover in this uh
fireside chat but we do each have some
parting words
um you know as we're about to embark on
this new year
2021 uh the thing i wanted to leave
listeners with uh to close out the
episode is
you know with the goals that i have for
the upcoming year a lot of them are more
process oriented a lot of them are more
habit related
and i talked about how a lot of it is
just kind of setting up the environment
to
increase my likelihood for success and
so what i want to encourage people to do
if you do set some ambitious goals for
2021
if you fall short if you start stumbling
um
don't internalize that as a just
objective
failure because i don't think it's that
simple
i think whenever we try to set a new
goal and achieve it or try to develop a
new habit
and we fall short or revert back to old
bad habits we try to avoid
we really ought to try to utilize that
as a
learning tool so like if you're falling
short of a goal
or you're failing to establish a new
habit instead of thinking like
this entire thing is just a willpower
equation and i either have enough or i
don't
um that's a pretty terrible way to frame
a goal in my opinion in your mindset
because it basically just sets you up
for like
2021 will be an enormous uphill climb
and i will either keep climbing or i
won't and i'll fail
like i think it's much more valuable and
in my opinion
again this is purely opinion based not
evidence based
whatsoever but in my opinion it's much
more valuable to say like interesting
i tried to do a thing i fell short i
wonder what i can
modify in my approach or maybe how i can
modify my environment
in a way that increases my likelihood to
actually succeed in it
moving forward you know so like if i
found that
moving the phone across the room and
setting the alarm every morning
if i was just crawling back in bed and
messing around on my phone for 30
minutes
i'd have to reassess and say okay my
environment modification did not work
to actually induce the behavior i was
looking for what is
a different environment modification i
can try you know but
but the important thing is i i don't
think it makes sense to frame it as
me versus my willpower let's see you
know who wins here
and see if i can just overcome this
challenge that drains me of mental
resources every single day from now on
i think you know recognize that you're
just kind of uh
you're kind of responding to your
environment you know like that you're
just kind of doing
what is there and be like okay well what
can i modify here in terms of my
approach that's actually going to help
me
so so don't beat yourself up if you fall
short try to learn from it and try to
modify your approach
and see if you can kind of tweak the
right variables to get yourself going
in the right direction all right so
uh for me i i first have to start get
i have to start by giving a shout out to
whatever engineer product designer at
facebook came up with the facebook
memories function
uh because i think that that is probably
the best piece of technology
ever ever designed for keeping people
epistemically honest
because like every time those pop up i i
scroll through them every day
and when i look back at every time i've
tried to give like
generalized life advice in the past i
just cringe like it
it's either very stupid or like in
hindsight it comes across as like
very self-righteous and sanctimonious
and i hate it every single time
yeah so anyway i mean looking back on it
every time i've tried to to give people
life advice before it was very stupid
and so i have no reason to believe that
it would be any less stupid now
uh so i'm going to go uh i'm going to go
back to the hits
i'm gonna play some hits i'm going to
give a piece of advice i've given on the
podcast before
that has received both the most feedback
and the highest ratio of positive
feedback of any recommendation
i've given on the podcast thus far so
listen up brine your chicken breasts
if you're making boneless skinless
chicken breasts it can be very dry it
can be very bland
if you brine them beforehand it will
make them so much juicier
so much more delicious uh somewhere
between a one to three percent brine
is the way to go uh depending how
uh how salty you like stuff so that
means for every liter of water
or one kilogram of water a thousand
grams of water
that's somewhere between 10 and 30 grams
of salt
and if you want to draw a little bit
more water in and and trust me this
really doesn't affect the macros to any
meaningful degree
somewhere between 10 and 30 grams of
sugar as well
just to increase the solutes in the
chicken keep more
keep more fluid locked in so a one to
three percent brine either just salt or
salt and sugar
make sure it's fully dissolved in the
water brine the chicken at least
overnight
and then you can cook it however you
want whether you're cooking it in a pan
baking it it will massively
improve your boneless skinless chicken
breast game so brine your chicken
uh that is those are my parting words
and advice to everyone out there in 2021
i got a quick question for you yeah you
said a one to three percent
brine solution yeah if you include
sugar should you adjust the salt to keep
it and
do you have to go like 15 and 15. no it
would it would be
one one to three percent salt and one to
three percent sugar
okay cool just just clarifying i don't
want people to start out 20 21 on the
wrong foot that's the last thing we want
absolutely not but yeah honestly it
makes
it makes such a huge difference and
really just like any
any lean cut of meat that has a tendency
to dry out brining it beforehand
is so so clutch so if you're making pork
loin brine your pork loin
if you're making pork chops brine your
pork chops uh
i i like chicken thighs really with
minimal preparation chicken thighs are
delicious but if you brine your chicken
thighs they'll be even better
so yeah any lean meat you're making
brine it beforehand
it will make it so much juicier so much
more flavorful
and and those are my parting words for
20 21. all right well i think that does
it for
the episode but it's your show so uh why
don't you take us out here
yeah uh thanks for listening um again
belated happy toyotathon thanks for
tuning in
um we will be back with a normal episode
pretty soon and yeah hope
hope 2021 goes great for all of you
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you